this morning we bring you our series
work in progress
in partnership with professional
networking site LinkedIn we explore the
future of jobs and issues facing the
American workforce federal statistics
show the unemployment rate reached a
17-year low in April it sits at three
point nine percent but some employers
are struggling to find the right kind of
workers to fill open positions Don
Dahler shows us what some towns are
doing to lure employees Don good morning
good morning for many people the chance
to leave home go away to school and
establish a career someplace new is part
of the American dream but for employers
in those hometowns watching the
potential workforce walk away can be
painful so some places are doing their
best to coax people back home and
they're willing to pay money to do it go
play go play go play after being away
from home for college in graduate school
Aaron Skinner is moving back to Eastern
Michigan but that was not his original
plan
I was really looking at either staying
in Atlanta or Grand Rapids the east side
of Michigan was kind of down low on my
on my list Skinner just received his
chiropractic degree in Atlanta behind
that smile and sense of accomplishment
lies a huge student loan debt can you
give me an idea about how much a very
nice house on the beach really about
close to three hundred three hundred
thousand yes so he jumped when he found
out that his home county st. Clair
Michigan would pay him to move home
they're gonna help you with your student
loans right right and in return you're
not going anywhere else you're coming
basically coming back home exactly
exactly
they're investing a lot of money into me
so I'm looking to invest that back into
the community and set up a practice or
work out of another practice Skinner's
taking advantage of st. Clair's come
home award offered to college-educated
people who grew up here and left to lure
them back to the county Skinner will get
up to fifteen thousand dollars towards
his student loans just to return it's a
deal Kaela parson ski couldn't pass up
her ten thousand dollar scholarship paid
for undergraduate loans which helped her
buy her first house there's a great
opportunity to financially it took a big
load off of me and I think it's worth it
can you see yourself here for a long
time yeah I couldn't lessee myself here
for a long time st. Clair County a
picturesque collection of small towns
and cities runs along Lake Huron and the
Saint Clair River a quiet county with
plenty of small-town appeal the average
annual salary here is just under 52
thousand dollars slightly more than the
national average why are you having to
pay people to come here I know it seems
ironic to think that Randy Myers helped
create the come home award let us focus
on talent and works with local
businesses and organizations to help
fund it to reverse a brain drain from
the area I think a part of it is that
the young people that grow up here they
get a chance to leave after high school
and go to college and they want to get
away from small-town America I mean you
know I can't play them the lure of
Detroit or Chicago nearby or the
Carolinas it draws people away less than
eighteen percent of st. Claire's a
hundred and sixty thousand residents
have a college degree
compare that with nearby Washtenaw
County home to University of Michigan
where more than half have a college
degree it's not a jobs problem this is
worth it this LinkedIn editor-at-large
chip cutter says the issue is educated
and trained workers so we're seeing this
real trend across the u.s. where places
like New York or San Francisco or Boston
these cities that just keep attracting
the type of educated workers that
employers crave it's kind of a rich get
richer situation it's why incentive
programs are popping up around counties
towns and small cities across America
like Crawford County Ohio Grant County
Indiana and the small town of Marni Iowa
the movie version of this is the plant
closes down and the town shrivels up and
dies that's not exactly what we're
seeing that's right it tends to be more
of a gradual problem where overtime
workers leave they don't necessarily
come back a town loses its population
and then the companies that are there
say we're having a really tough time
finding workers it may not be as
dramatic as a Hollywood story but it's
just as urgent st. Claire has had 45
applicants for the come home award since
the program began
in 2016 they have awarded them to ten
people it doesn't sound like a lot but
Randy Myers told me that even a few
people coming back planting roots and
starting families can make a difference
and I have to tell you both Kayla and
Aaron say that their friends are saying
oh that's a good deal we have to look
into this but what a great idea
especially if you like the hometown
where you grow up I don't envy people
that have roots of where they grew
because I traveled as a little kid and
don't really have a home base
I think it's nice if you have a home
base and you like it and it used to be
you had to travel you had to leave home
to find work yeah that's not the way it
is anymore this economy and so many
people have student loan debts it's a
great idea to help forgive those or pay
them off yes very nice Don Dahler